maintenant en plus d'enfants que vous
présentera cotait ce matin
[Applaudissements]
vous devez croire en vos convictions
devez vivre pour vos convictions et vous
devez être prêt à mourir pour votre
ambition
mon père est pas révolutionnaire
m'a dit que vous avez eu pas mal de
problèmes
et
[Musique]
il faut que tu puisses thouars déjanté
d'extérieur à savoir qu'il souffrait
sur cible et de pouvoir rassembler tous
les révolutionnaires il une grande
partie du toit
tu peux une des normes l'absence utilise
là pour faire une différence
on adore s'amuser et pas que tu fais un
tableau pour le système n'est pas
toujours joli geste est vrai en
rapportant la ville à vue juridique et
décrire leur réalité
je sais de source sûre que le mba est à
un dossier de 4000 pas juste 4000 avec
excel pourrait devenir un mouvement sont
toutes noires en utilisant des symboles
comme tanguay hors la loi wazemmes et
régions le nombre de ces gens pour les
aider à s'en sortir
beaucoup de gens plein au monde mal
elles sont pas en moi je suis un homme
d'être plus que level c'est une famille
c'est très simple vous êtes avec nous
est contre non plus un puisque les
élèves voulaient utiliser sa voix pour
éduquer et pour attendre les présents si
en fait cher la peau il en subira les
conséquences
on doit créer un mouvement pour notre
communauté et faire en sorte qu'elles
soient en sécurité
les caméras sont sûrement et touba
donner les outils dans tu auras besoin
poursuit détruire doigt mais non je n'ai
pas de haine contre lui en furie contre
ce système
la seule façon que chebira 10 et d'être
responsable de ce que je fais
[Musique]